non-minimalists
what to do when you're overwhelmed with
the process
of removing stuff and forward progress
becomes
difficult i would rephrase the question
a little bit here
i would say how do you let go when
you're overwhelmed by decluttering
yeah because that's what's happening
right now and this happened to me as
well
when i dealt with my mom's stuff after
she died i was overwhelmed with that but
not as much as when i got home
yeah and i realized like oh i'm an
organized hoarder i my
my house looked like an advertisement
for a container store
and and so it was overwhelming where do
i even
start and i wish i would have you know
the reason we've come up with all these
rules whether it's the minimalist rule
book or the 30-day minimalism game or
whatever it is
is because i wish i would have had these
things to start
the 30-day minimalism game in particular
is actually how i start
is a iteration on how i started what i
asked myself early on
because i didn't know what to do i
didn't know where to start and so i just
sort of threw my hands up and i was
exacerbated
and most people that's what happened you
were exacerbated by
your stuff and so i said what if i just
got rid of one
item one material possession a day for
for a month
just one item a day for a month it's 30
days
30 items what would happen well it turns
out i got rid of way more than 30 items
because as you get that momentum if i
get rid of one thing today i'm not going
to stop with one thing
right and that was the whole point of
the minimalism game
where you start with with one item
but the next day you are able to get let
go a little bit more so two items
next day three items a little bit more
each day because you get that momentum
and what i find is some people
will tweet us or they'll message us on
youtube or whatever and they'll say
hey after like day five i found i
already got rid of 500 things
because i i just needed that initial
spark to start
letting go it starts this
beautiful conflagration of of getting
rid of stuff so
yes i mean obviously i think you start
with a 30-day minimalism game the
minimalists.com
game and you just go from there this
question makes me think about uh being
on the exercise bike
i turn the resistance like way up yeah
and then within
this doesn't happen all the time but
sometimes i turn it too far up
and i'm like oh crap like i can't
continue this resistance
so my inclination is to just like take
off all the resistance and keep going
but i'm like if i take all the
resistance off
then i'm going to lose this momentum
that i've built during this bike ride so
the question is if you have too much
resistance right now
how can you take a little bit of the
resistance off so
you know if you are overwhelmed with uh
with decluttering
and you're tackling your house all at
once
then just move it to like a closet or
something just
don't lose that momentum though but yeah
it's okay to turn on the resistance a
little bit
i love that analogy the 30 the 30 day
minimalism game is a great way to
because to me it seems like a good
middle ground you're still getting rid
of stuff
it actually turns up the resistance
slowly for you yeah because imagine if
you had to start
the opposite now some people do this but
if you had to get rid of
31 items the first day you'd be like
that might be too much it's too much
resistance to start
it's just like when you start doing the
exercise bike you don't crank it all the
way up immediately
right it's slowly turning that
resistance up i love that analogy even
better
it made me think like when i turn the
resistance up is because i start out
at a level that i think like oh this is
going to be
a good resistance to keep me working out
and then it's really easy
yeah and i'm like oh i can crank this up
and then i do crank it up and it's great
for
a very short period of time right so
yeah i could see where
going through that decluttering process
you get really excited you start
you know you turn it up and then you get
to a point where you're like oh no i've
overwhelmed myself and so yeah you got
to turn it back down
i think the last simple sort of trick
here
is start with the things that are easier
for you
you don't want to start with your most
precious most sentimental items now you
might have a bunch of those that
actually end up not
being sentimental items for you and we
already talked about that a bit earlier
on
but you you will have some things you're
like i know
that triple x orange sweatshirt that i
haven't worn
since 2003 just mail it to josh
yeah i gotta get bigger clothes to cover
up these muscles that's right
yeah but there are things that you
absolutely know that you know
they're just in the way start with those
because that will start to get you the
momentum
and then you'll start questioning the
other things that you know you should
probably get rid of as well